the creators of Game of Thrones are now
tackling Star Wars they're moving there
one of their next projects is going to
be making a film in the Star Wars saga
yes and there's been this persistent
rumor rumor and you said rumor same
thing I was in Australia for a week and
it really got to me there's no room at
there's a rumor that you are in it no
listen to this rumor mill I'm let's not
rule anything out all of a sudden but
why don't you go with it and say yeah
sure as I can't because it'll sound like
let the story oh they didn't it George
Lucas kind of set and his delightful
wife and I mentioned it to somebody and
then the Star Wars thing came out and
that I've been talking to them and all
of a sudden it was people you know put
two and two together and came up with 12
million and it's it's it was George
they're diving down obviously and and
myself and I'd let yourself know and
they're all of a sudden they're trying
to go well you already be bringing it
and suddenly I'm am I'm all be one
Kenobi I did I did him a chap I get have
a chat with they're done Weiss about it
when we're and we came up neither the
idea of I might do old Jar Jar Binks
trilogy no one wants to see you be old
jerk know what the one wants to see Jar
Jar Binks again old rumor going yeah the
old Jar Jar comes back